joining us right now from the tampa bay
times who is kind enough to call into
the show all season long now that the
season is over i guess this is kind of
an exit interview in a way but we always
like to chat with you rick stroud how
are you sir
i'm doing well now do i get the physical
as well
i need to see your insurance card um you
know i'll hang up and listen uh no um so
uh what uh what's the first blush
reaction to what happened yesterday in
tampa
rick oh my goodness um well listen i i
don't know how far this team would have
gone beyond on beyond sunday had they
won that remarkable comeback and and if
they'd have pulled it off i think we'd
be talking about a rams collapse
more than tom brady's comeback but
um
you know i
it's it's a disappointing right when you
when you don't have the confetti fall in
your head and you have a guy like tom
brady the finality of an nfl season as
bruce arians correctly said is
is you know not good
uh and
you know now
i think there really is some uncertainty
about brady in his future and that
doesn't mean i would be surprised if a
couple weeks from now he says yeah baby
let's go let's you know let's get this
band back together or whatever
um but at least for the first time you
know when he extended his contract
back in march there didn't seem to be
any question that he was he was down
until he was 45 you know i'm going to
play it on 45 maybe i could play to 150.
um
and now you know you don't hear that
from him and i think there's some people
really even at at the bucks that that
aren't sure what he's going to do but
they're certainly going to give him all
the space he needs and then you know
maybe there's some questions they need
to answer with respect to what does this
team look like next year i mean they you
know 11 out of the 22 guys that started
the game yesterday are going to be free
agents and
it's not going to be the same as it was
a year ago when they wanted to run it
back so
you know we'll get some answers probably
here
sooner than later because they need to
know by the time they get to free agency
for certain
um but there is there is you know a lot
of questions about about the bucks and
and and what it'll look like a year from
now what do you know right now if
anything about what brady's decision
making will be formulated or how it's
formulated
at all well what i was told um when he
got here is that
you know two two big things um with him
are the most important one is his health
um and by all accounts he got out of
this season a year ago he played with a
torn mcl as we know but he got out of
this season feeling pretty good i mean
he took some hits and some games against
the saints and others
um but it's remarkable how he's kept
himself in shape certainly you watch
that throw the 55-yard bomb to mike
evans there's nothing wrong at all with
his arm strength uh he can still spin it
and
you know that said
uh
you know they got two offensive linemen
that are free agents this year you know
you've got to you've got to secure all
that up but if he feels good that's the
first question the second one is
you know his family and you know
tom brady works really hard at being a
great dad and a great husband and
you know he wants to be an all-pro at
that too um you know he's got a 14 year
old son
that lives in new york um you know and
two kids obviously here in giselle and
every year she asks them have you had
enough and
i just i believe that when you when you
sign the extension even though it wasn't
binding obviously that there had to at
least been a discussion right that you
know look i'm going to do this so you're
not surprised when you read about it i'd
like to play to 145 now
what could change that
anything right it means kids are getting
older they're involved in sports of
their own um
you know certainly he has enough to do
off the field with all his businesses
and the brady clothing line which by the
way is at nordstrom's right here in
tampa it looks really nice
um shameless plug but you know it's it's
anybody's guess right but he just enjoys
it so much it but now i don't have any
question that he he will play and and
would play
if but the pull that he feels is greater
the tug greater a little bit every year
with his family and these have been two
magical years for him i think and for
the bucks obviously
it didn't end with both super bowls but
if you take just the combined success
they've had
i mean aside from going one and seven
against the rams and the saints there's
the two they're like 29-3 or 28-3
against everybody else so
um
you know that's a long-winded answer
saying i don't think anybody knows but
there is genuine concern or at least
um
you know the question is there as to
whether he'll be back next season or not
and that that question still exists at
the box right now well i guess the fact
that rick stroud tampa eight times here
on the rich eyes and show i guess the
fact that you did not mention roster as
a concern for brady is a good thing
obviously um
and uh on that front uh i guess
the question is
do you think part of him this may be
another reason why he would want to come
back
is that if not for the injuries and then
one of his crucial receivers strip
sacking himself
uh in new jersey
um that he would still be playing today
that he sits there and he thinks about
that what do you think rick yeah i i
think that um roster is i didn't mention
it but that's on me um i think the
roster is important obviously and
especially when two of your offensive
linemen including the pro bowl center is
a free agent right now it's a chicken in
the egg right you can get a heck of a
lot of guys back to come and play with
tom brady if they know he's going to be
the quarterback you know so if he's
waiting for them to sign or something
well that's not going to happen until
after the start of pre-hc which is too
late anyway
um but they're not in the salary cap
situation that say the packers are um
they're going to have some money
there's a lot of free agents so a lot of
those contracts will drop off obviously
they're about middle of the pack with
respect to salary cap space they have
kicked some you know the can down the
road to to get everybody back a year ago
so it won't be like you know all 22 are
coming back but you also have the draft
and you have free agency and and he's
the biggest draw in free agency
so i think he would be confident that
jason light and bruce would do
everything they could to put the best
team around them that would include
chris godwin right if you franchise them
again or brought them back that would
probably include
um you know one of your offensive
alignment or both that would include the
carlton davis and and you know some of
the key elements of their team so
there's enough talent and still a young
core
on this team that he can win with
especially in this division
but can you win it all and and i think
tom thinks he can win it all with
anybody you know and you know i think
gronk would come back if tom comes back
i think that those two are somehow
related in my mind so
um i don't he's not he's not scared of
anyone we know that but i think it is i
think it is still he would want to know
what the plan is and
you know they'd have to give him some
assurances and and i think they would do
this that they will mortgage
any future move any mountain to make
sure that tom brady is a quarterback if
he wants to play because business is
good here in tampa bay right now folks
let me let me assure you that they're
relevant they've been to a super bowl
they've won 14 games this year they're
very happy about what tom brady has
brought them and they'd like to keep
they'd like to keep this going yeah
first division since the oughts as well
i mean so
yeah obviously things are things are
going well there rick stroud here on the
rich hissing show i noticed you said
business is good and not booming
um
you know and i am i am i guess mandated
to linger here a little bit because
you're already hearing the conversation
that
that that what was missing in a way um
clearly you know
a quick game would have been required um
yesterday the way that that brady was
getting hit and then more targets um
with playmakers that you'd have to be
concerned about certainly if you got
jaylen ramsey with uh one side of the
field or or however they were playing it
and today um my our friend brandon
marshall does have an interview out with
um antonio brown where he said that
aryans never
wanted him there and was very negative
about his presence there and so on and
so forth and i know that there's a large
grain and there's a lot of salt
but do you think like what what did
happen any any more ideas in the last
two three weeks about what did happen
with antonio brown and if he was there
yesterday there would have been a
different result
um there's no question antonio brown
makes him a better football team and not
by a little but probably by a lot
um he's just that kind of player you
know he missed all those weeks came back
against uh what was it carolina i think
had 10 catches for over 100 yards and
and you know the talent is there
talent's never been the issue
um you know i guess it's my fault for
writing about the fake vaccination cards
and that led to the suspension and then
maybe he wasn't going gonna get enough
money and then he wanted his bonuses
guaranteed so i'll take the fall on that
one but at the end of the day um antonio
brown was a ticking time bomb
um you know it was it was a matter of
when not if and you know they got a
super bowl out of them they got eight
games he even caught a touchdown there
they brought him back that was what they
chose to do
and it wound up you know in in the the
the show that was you know metlife
stadium with the stripping to the waist
so
um
i don't know that you you could have
predicted it would go down like that so
publicly and so so bitterly
but yeah could they have been a better
team with antonio i think that's why he
was here i think tom knew that
um i think tom generally cares about all
his teammates including antonio i don't
think it was just about winning but that
guy's a next level type dude and that
that's what tom brady wants around him
because his football iq is so high
that he just knows how to make himself
available and when he gets the ball in
his hands the guy can make unbelievable
things happen but you know the sport is
more more than just talent as we know
it's a team sport and there was not a
bigger me guy
in the locker room you know than antonio
brown and that's
if you listen to bruce arians and other
people that were in the locker room at
halftime up there in new york that's all
he was talking about was his touches and
his you know targets and so on and so
forth so
that necessarily you know doesn't
doesn't make you a winner but if you're
asking me would they have won the game i
don't know if they win the game the game
certainly goes a little bit better but i
think the bigger factor was they were
just a beat up football team and and
once it once it got to the offensive
line level even the guys coming in like
josh wells couldn't hold up especially
against a really good defensive line and
even having said all that they still
clawed back in and tied the game
and and but for just a horrendous call
that i can't explain or todd bowles
probably will have to explain um they
may win that game so um
yeah i mean one guy does he change the
whole thing maybe but i i it's just hard
to hard to know the last one for you is
what about the staff right um aryan's
coming back and what's his future and
then the rest of the staff
um being intact
coming back what do you think well i
mean they've got two guys that have had
head coaching interviews and um you know
from what i hear i think bowles has a
shot
i don't know if it's in jacksonville
that would seem the natural place for me
a
quarterback
with a young quarterback like trevor
lawrence ties to the area all of that
i think for todd bowles i think he's
interviewing teams as much as they would
interview him he's been down the road
with the new york jets he knows what he
has to have to win he's not going to go
to a situation where that doesn't exist
i don't think he has a burning desire
just to take any job although you know
if he was offered one he'd have to
consider it
they're ready to move on if they have to
on offense bruce arian said today he
would go back to calling plays which i'm
surprised that is a surprise um
and i think he would still use his staff
to do most of the scripts and some of
the heavy lifting during the week um i
know he's trying to groom thad lewis
who's a
assistant receivers coach that was
quarterback at duke and played in four
or five or six different organizations
he's really high on him but he might not
think he's quite ready yet and i think
you know in bruce saying that that
seemed like a little message to tom
brady to me that hey if we lose byron
and tom does a lot of game planning
let's be honest but if he loses byron
that hey you can work with me i'll work
with you you get the big guy you know
everything will be fine so
that's kind of interesting i thought
always interesting talking to you rick
stroud thanks for the call let's do this
down the line so
much
to talk about with the uh now dethroned
if you will world champs much
appreciated thank you for the whole year
and uh and over the next couple weeks
when you answer our call thank you
anytime rich dethroned i that sounds so
bad i mean huh i don't know what
happened
no you're not you're not you're welcome
back anytime you passed the physical we
got we got everything back so uh okay
good glad i'm good all right thanks rich
keep your playbook
we'll see you soon there you go that's
rick stroud everyone hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here